this is what life under occupation looks
like Israeli military vehicles
accompanied by bulldozers storming
Palestinian cities and towns
intimidating and killing Palestinians
the early Sunday raid targeted the newer
Shams refugee camp in tulkarim in the
north of the occupied West Bank people
here are largely unarmed but some young
men have formed fighting groups
including 21 year old usaid Abal Ali he
was killed during the confrontations
that followed the raid
another man a 32 year old father of two
was killed after being shot in the head
now his pregnant wife will only have
stories of her late husband Abid to tell
her newborn
it's been a horrifying night for
children
tells us she lives in the camp and says
the Israeli forces destroyed homes and
damaged roads for nearly five hours
if older people were afraid you can
imagine the children they want to break
us but we won't be broken
this line was hit by bullets I have to
fix it now soon after the Israeli Army
withdrew from turkarim electrician
came to minimize the risks see these
exposed wires it was connected to the
electricity Network on the rods so I had
to come and turn off the power so no one
gets harmed it could kill someone
he told us his fixes are only temporary
Israeli forces raided this refugee camp
less than a month ago and called severe
damages just as local authorities were
finishing off reconstructing the main
street it's been damaged again in some
days raids
the next trade could happen at any time
these young men tell us they're
Gathering tires in preparation they say
they have little means of Defending
themselves and hope these tires will
make it harder for the Army to rate the
camp but their efforts may not amount to
much against a heavily militarized Army
the occupied West Bank
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera